today on the matt walsh show the media
is reporting that i was part of a
radical chaotic extremist dangerous mob
at the school board meeting a few days
ago that's not exactly how i remember it
this is just one of the lies they're
telling us part of their latest push to
convince you to panic over covet all
over again also a woman in california
has been charged with murder after
throwing her infant off of a roof she
obviously deserves to rot in prison for
what she did and yet i can't help but
notice that if she had killed her infant
only a few months earlier and for the
same reason we would be told to
celebrate her and media matters
publishes a report highlighting the
supposed transphobia of the daily wire
in a transparent effort to get us booted
from youtube and finally in our daily
cancellation we'll try to figure out
whether it is actually sexist to
describe a woman as nice jen pasaki says
that it is we'll talk about that and
much more today on the matt wall show
you know there is nothing in this life
more important than protecting your
online data well maybe a few things food
shelter whiskey that kind of thing but
still very important to protect your
online data and that's why you need
expressvpn and it is the best vpn on the
market for a number of very clear
reasons expressvpn doesn't log your
activity online lots of cheap or free
vpns make money by selling your data to
advertisers but expressvpn doesn't do
this they even developed a technology
trusted server that makes their vpn
servers incapable of storing any data at
all also their speed expressvpn now uses
lightweight a new vpn protocol they
engineer to make user uh speeds faster
than ever i've tried many vpns on the
market and i found that they always kind
of slow the connection down and that's a
big problem big hurdle but that's not
the case with expressvpn it's also easy
to use which is another important thing
for me anyway
no technical skills are needed you just
fire up the app you tap one button
even i can't screw it up and you connect
and it's as simple as that so protect
yourself with the vpn that i use and
trust use my link expressvpn.com walsh
today you get an extra three months free
on a one year package that's
expressvpn.comwalsh visit
expressvpn.comwalsh
to learn more
an article in the texas tribune
yesterday garnered a lot of attention
and it's not hard to see why the paper
reported the incredibly startling fact
that 5800 children in the state had been
hospitalized with covid in just the span
of one week
now that is needless to say
shocking horrified nearly 6 000 in a
week
and the story was shared far and wide
including by prominent people in the
media
who were amplifying this message and it
helped us cement into people's mind that
covet is now suddenly a significant
danger to kids
the only problem is that the incredible
fact was incredible but not a fact
the tribune sometime later issued a
correction which is really more of a of
a retraction and here it is they said an
earlier version of this story overstated
the number of children who have been
hospitalized in texas recently with kova
19. the story said over 5800 children
had been hospitalized during a seven day
period in august according to the cdc
that number correctly referred to
children hospitalized with cover 19
since the pandemic began in actuality
783 children were admitted to texas
hospitals with coven 19 between july 1st
and august 9th of this year
ah so the central detail the point that
precipitated the article in the first
place was wrong
no not just wrong but wildly
fantastically wrong this again is not a
correction that's a retraction
that's like publishing a whole article
saying
bigfoot was spotted he's real we know
and then and then the correction comes
oh never mind actually this was just uh
this was just a bear walking in the
woods that's that's not a correction
that is going back on the whole point of
the story
rather than nearly 6 000 hospitalized in
a week
it was fewer than 800
and not in a week but in 40 days in a
state with seven and a half million
children and that's assuming of course
you can even trust the 800 figure
and what i certainly don't trust is the
excuse that this was all a mistake
far from us
far from a mistake it would seem to be
another intentional fear tactic a
purposeful ploy to exploit every
parent's deepest fear
i mean it cannot be a coincidence that
suddenly
when most people are tired of mask
mandates and have no patience for
lockdowns
now the media starts focusing on
children trying to convince us that
children are dying left and right from
the virus why well it's the one thing
that can make even reasonable people
panic
if you're screaming covet is coming for
you and people are no longer reacting to
that like you want them to
try covet is coming for your kids
and then see what happens
yet still if you dig into the numbers
the truth continues to reveal itself an
article on the medical news site medpage
today speculates that the dreaded delta
variant might
be more severe in kids maybe perhaps but
qualifies this speculation by admitting
that there's no data to support it only
anecdotes
as far as the data goes it says reading
from the article
as for hospitalizations which the aap
tracks in 23 states and new york city
kids accounted for 1.5 to 3.5 percent of
total cumulative hospitalizations and
0.1
to 1.9 percent of all pediatric coveted
cases resulted in hospitalization
cdc's covet data tracker shows a total
of about 46 000 hospital admissions for
kids under 18 since august 1 2020 with a
current seven-day average of 203
pediatric hospitalizations daily close
to the peak seven-day average of 217
during this past winter surge for the
week ending in january 9 2021. this
week's figure is up from a seven day
average of 168 the week prior aap
collects mortality data from 43 states
new york city puerto rico and guam
telling 371 pediatric deaths since
mid-may 2020 children children accounted
for zero percent
to .2
of all coveted deaths in those areas and
seven states reported no child deaths at
all
of all pediatric cova cases in those
areas zero percent to .03 percent
resulted in death
they the aap report stated quote at this
time it appears that severe illness due
to cover 19 is uncommon among children
which is everything we already knew and
by the way
as you just saw on the report
um we haven't even yet reached as far as
child hospitalization we haven't reached
the peak
which is which is thankfully a very
small peak um compared to what it was
even in the winter
yet in the winter
the media wasn't really talking about
child hospitalizations
that's that's what they're talking about
now
so to summarize the data tells us what
the data has always told us
covid is not a serious threat to kids
despite the fervent wishes of the
lunatic hobgoblins in the media it's not
thank god it's not
but no worries you know if they can't
win the debate with the facts they can
always retreat to the tried and true
method of casting the other side of the
debate as violent extremists if you
listen to the reports about the school
board meetings and protests in tennessee
this week and we're dumb enough to
somehow believe them you'd come away
with the impression that we so-called
anti-masters um
and some of us by the way might actually
be anti-mass massacres as in we don't
want to wear masks anyway anywhere
that's where i fall on this question
but there are a lot of people who maybe
don't mind the masks they just don't
want their kids to be forced to wear
them
those distinctions aren't made we're all
just anti-maskers whatever
and they tell us that these school board
meetings
descended um that we kind of descended
onto the scene like mongol hordes
subjugating our enemies
leaving them trembling at our feet and
frankly that sounds kind of appealing i
must admit to me
but it's not what happened
what happened is that concerned parents
gathered spoke their mind some of them
had signs
and that was about it
there were some raised voices perhaps a
smattering of impolite words were
shouted but but that's as far as it went
which is not the impression you would
get from first the local media reports
for example the local website nashville
scene
reported on the meeting that i attended
with this headline
mask mandates lead to chaos at school
board
meetings on a national level salon
reports anti-mask mob swarm school board
meeting
this latter headline is in reference to
the meeting down in williamson county
which i have learned from salon i
attended myself now that was news to me
as i thought i attended the nashville
metro meeting
i didn't think i was at that other one
salon says that i was all right i'll go
with them what do i know
in any case the williamson county
meeting was by all accounts you know a
larger and noisier crowd but there was
no violence
no crimes were committed
nothing that lives up to the image of
chaos and a swarming mob
emotions were high that's for sure and
for good reason and those emotions ran
both ways as pro-masked parents melted
down in tears trembling in terror at the
thought of their child being murdered by
a mask-less student breathing on them
the daily beast though takes the
propaganda prize i think with this
headline
they report proud boys are teaming up
with anti-masters to threaten school
boards over coveted mandates
proud boys
all i've seen are middle-aged parents
upset that their children are being
forced to wear masks all day without
anything approaching a proper
justification for it
where are the proud boys
while the writer explains about a about
a dozen paragraphs into this article
uh we're told that a few proud boys
showed up at a couple of school board
meetings in florida a month ago
and they also tell us that some proud
boys spoke out about critical race
theory in new hampshire in july
they put proud boys and anti-masters in
the headline and one of the examples
they give us of two
doesn't even have anything to do with
masks
this part of the article confused me as
well it says quote meanwhile in
nashville on tuesday night conservative
commentator matt walsh took the
microphone at a school board meeting
despite being a vocal advocate for
homeschooling walsh who did not return a
request for comment because i never got
a request as far as i know claimed that
masking students was child abuse pushed
by adults experiencing munchausen
syndrome by proxy and that there was no
evidence that covenanting affects
children the tennessean reported
cover 19 can affect children and the
delta variant has resulted in a spike in
child hospitalizations
yeah one problem here
um
i mean i did say this stuff about child
abuse and manchester by proxy all that
is true uh but i never said that there
was no evidence that covid affects
children never said that
a reporter for the tennessean who was at
the meeting and sitting three feet from
me did indeed report that i had said
that but she was lying
she was like a truly courageous warrior
for the truth sitting right next to me
and tweeting lies about what i said
unbeknownst to me at the time
now i corrected her publicly
and at any rate the video is available
to watch the daily beast is repeating a
lie from a local reporter even though
they could watch the video and hear the
truth for themselves and i know they did
watch the video because they accurately
quote it elsewhere
it's a pretty big difference
no one is claiming
that cover 19 doesn't affect children of
course it does
even if they get a mild case of the
sniffles which is what it is for most of
them still that's still an effect it has
it has an effect
just a very mild effect most of the time
this is what the panic pushers are
reduced to misinformation
mischaracterizations flat out lies
all while painting the opposition as
dangerous extremists and militant
radicals
and and what is the position that we
radicals so-called are taking
it's worth emphasizing this point
our radical position
is the position
that all people everywhere in the
country held unquestionably until last
year
our radical plot
is to simply continue living as we all
had lived up to now
taking reasonable precautions
practicing good hygiene all that's great
i mean i was doing that before i don't
know about you guys i didn't start
washing my hands with coved
the way some people talk it's like they
just they just discovered it during kobe
which is a little gross but
um doing that but but also willing to
endure the minor risks involved in
walking around with our mouths and noses
showing breathing fresh air interacting
with people face to face
okay that's that's all we're saying
that's how everyone has lived
even during pandemics
that's how almost everyone has lived
and there have been a lot of pandemics
in the past
they're the ones pushing for a truly
radical change to society they want us
to wholly transform the way we live our
lives they want us to completely adjust
how we perform basic risk calculations
they want us to agree
that a risk of death which doesn't even
approach anywhere close to one percent
is intolerable
all of this is new it's extremely new
radically new
as always with the left
they insist on the radical change while
casting us as the radicals for wanting
to keep things as they were that is we
want to do
what they themselves were doing
yesterday
they were walking along a path and
verged off of it and we didn't follow
right away
so then we're not only wrong but somehow
we turn into violent dangerous
revolutionaries
that's the game
it's worked for them many times
and so i imagine they'll keep on playing
it
now let's get to our five headlines
now a quick word from legacy box they
say that you can't know who you are
unless you know where you've been i
think they say that or if they don't say
it then i'm saying it and it isn't it is
uh true it's an important truth because
so much of our identity is tied up in
our memories
of ourselves and the problem is that a
lot of those memories now are stored in
antiquated technology there you got them
on
you know camcorder
physical pictures and that kind of thing
maybe you got them in a basement or up
in an attic in a box
and you don't have access to them you're
not really using them and they can also
be destroyed and that's why you need a
legacy box with legacy box you can
reclaim all the priceless footage you
haven't been able to see in years the
service couldn't be simpler use their
kit to safely send the moments that you
want preserved on whatever technology
it's on their team will create a digital
archive by hand and then you'll receive
your new copies stored on the cloud a
thumb drive or a dvd whatever you want
along with all the original media that
you sent them having done this myself i
was impressed by how how easy it was
throw it in the box send it they send it
back and also how quickly uh they were
able to do all this legacy box has
helped over one million families restore
and protect their most cherished
memories so visit
legacybox.com to take advantage of this
limited time offer for 50 off and
discover the magic of bringing your pass
back into view anytime anywhere take
advantage of this exclusive offer today
and then use their kit whenever you're
ready that's legacybox.com walsh to say
50 off legacybox.comwalsh
okay so say staying on uh sort of the
same subject here
joe biden yesterday
um talking about
what happened in tennessee the chaos
the swarming mobs
um he uh stood up for for those who are
mandating masks and in fact said that
they are not only right but they're
heroes
let's listen to that
i know there are a lot of people out
there trying to
turn a public safety measure that is
children wearing masks in school
so they can be safe into a political
dispute
and that this isn't about politics
it's about keeping our children safe i
saw a video and reports from a tennessee
uh
a protesters threatening doctors and
nurses
were before school board making the case
that to keep kids safe
there should be mandatory masks
and as they walked out these doctors
were threatened these nurses were
threatened
you know our healthcare workers are
heroes
they were the heroes when there was no
vaccine
many of them gave their lives trying to
save others
and their heroes again
with a vaccine
they're doing their best to care for the
people refusing to get vaccinated
and unvaccinated folks are
being hospitalized and dying as a result
of not being vaccinated
okay first of all every time
you hear these people say it's not about
politics why are you making it political
always remember that these are the same
people including joe biden himself
who said during uh during trump's
presidency
that they probably wouldn't trust the
vaccine
if trump is in charge
that was the position that many of these
people took including joe biden himself
oh but it's not political
you know what he means is don't take
politics into account now now that i am
in charge
yeah you're supposed to simply trust me
without hesitation
also as far as heroes um
you know
a few things there even if someone is a
hero
that doesn't make them above criticism
so that's not a defense
of
what these people are advocating
the doctors and supposed medical
professionals who are advocating for
masking kids
even if they're heroes
that doesn't make them right about what
they're saying so the fact that they're
heroes is irrelevant
if they make a claim
and then i say i disagree with that
claim and here's why
is a non-sequitur for you to respond to
me but they're heroes
so
and also
uh no they're not
some medical professionals might be
heroic
i'm perfectly willing to believe that
there are there are
heroic medical professionals out there
who have done heroic things both in the
field of medicine and outside of it
but
simply um
simply doing your job as a medical
professional does not make you heroic
you're this is your job you're paid to
do it you don't have to do it it's a
line of work you chose to get into
which is which is which is great
i'm glad you found a line of work that
you um are passionate about and we need
people to do this do these jobs
but nobody this is a blanket statement
nobody is a hero simply for doing a job
that they're paid to do
there are jobs that provide you
[Music]
a a greater than than the average number
of opportunities to act heroically
police officers would be one example i'm
not gonna sit here and say that every
single police officer is a hero
that would be absurd of course they're
not
they're bad cops out there
there are a lot of cops are just kind of
like average they they
you know they they react like any
average person would
um given the dangers that they face and
then there are some cops who actually
are heroes and actorically
same goes for for medical professionals
but this is a tactic we always see from
those in power
you know and it kind of changes
depending on what
their they want us to believe or they're
trying to get us to do
they'll take a certain profession or a
certain group of people and say these
are all heroes
there was a time
not all that long ago
when politicians used to say all cops
are heroes
and now they flip that around and now
all basically all cops are villains
uh and then one other point about about
heroism
you you can't be a hero
when someone else is making the
sacrifice so when it comes to masking
children
there is nothing heroic leaving aside
whether it's right or not which it isn't
there's certainly nothing heroic
about advocating that all children have
to wear masks every day for eight hours
a day because that's not a sacrifice
you're making you're forcing your kids
to make it or other people's kids to
make it
it's not heroic on your part
real fundamental fact about heroism here
heroism is a sacrifice that you make
you're asking kids to do that
and by the way with with these with
these mask mandates for kids
they're the only ones
along with the staff in the school
but
our kids are going to be among the only
ones that are actually required to wear
masks
for that amount of time every single day
for seven or eight hours sustained time
like they have to wear the mask every
single second during the school
presumably they can take it off for
lunch at least i hope
and put it right back on
but almost seven eight straight hours of
wearing masks
i got news for you the medical
professionals don't do that
they wear the mask if they're dealing
with a patient
um which is what a lot of doctors and
people working in hospitals had always
done
but then they leave the room they take
it off
they're not just walking around for
eight hours straight wearing a mask
so that is an enormous sacrifice
that we are asking kids to make
specifically and almost nobody else
now you are requiring kids to make a
heroic sacrifice
against their will
which makes you a lot of things um but
one of the things is not going to be a
hero
all right let's go here from this is
from the new york post it says a cow
it's a
horrific story
but there's
an important point to be made in
relation to it so i'm going to read some
of this story to you
a california mom has been convicted of
pushing her seven-month-old son to his
death from the fourth story
of a hospital parking garage according
to prosecutors
sonia hermosio of 41 was found guilty
wednesday of one felony account of first
degree murder and one felony account of
assault on a child causing death the
jury will determine whether the mom was
legally sane when she sent um no medina
junior plunging to his death at the
children's hospital of orange county
uh hermosillo allegedly suffered from
mental health issues after the birth of
the boy who has received treatment for
medical issues such as congenital
muscular
torticolis it's a condition in which an
infant holds his or he her head tilted
to one side
um prosecutor
of the case said he was sick and his
mother didn't want him she made a
cold-hearted decision to kill her child
prosecutors allege that her ceo drove to
the hospital on a day that the boy
didn't have an appointment
then took off the helmet he was wearing
and pushed him off the garage
the d.a said hermesa then walked into
inside the hospital validated her
parking
and drove away
the boy died
two days after the fall so he suffered
immensely
for two days and then died
in her police interview she allegedly
told the police that she had hate
resentment and anger toward the boy
because he's sick
and that's why she killed him
if found legally saying she could she
could face 25 years to life in prison
well 25 years would be yet another
enormous injustice let's
obviously
what this woman did is uh is
the word monstrous doesn't come close to
capturing it
this should be a a death penalty
situation
which is not going to be in california
but it should be
i personally would be in favor of
you convict her in a court of law
legally
pass down the sentence
and if i was the judge and it was a
legal option the sentence would be
we're going to take you up to the 10th
story or the 20th story of this building
and toss you out and that's going to be
your penalty that's your that's your
method of execution
that to me would be justice
and and i got news for you i don't care
if you're legally sane or not
that makes no difference
you may you you did something
horrifically evil and you will suffer
the consequences for it
and we're not going to keep you around
why
why should we
yeah i i i just i don't buy it
at all
most of these insanity please i don't
buy it
you know an actual insane person who
doesn't know what they're doing
that is uh that's like someone those
people you know who those people are
because they don't have homes and they
don't drive cars
and um and they don't function in
society at all you find them sitting on
the side of the road on the sidewalk
talking to themselves okay those are the
insane people who really don't know
what's happening they don't know what
they're doing
those are the people who if they commit
a horrific crime
they should still go to prison but uh
maybe the insanity aspect comes into
play because they are they literally
have no grasp on reality whatsoever
but if you have someone who's basically
functioning in society
um and is showing some knowledge that
that what they did was wrong then that's
i i don't care about their mental health
problems
they knew enough
and should suffer the consequences
all that being said
let's think about this for a second
seven-month-old son
was murdered
why was he murdered because the because
he was had had suffered physical
disabilities
and the mother was a
selfish monstrous sociopath and didn't
want to take care
and hated him for the way that he was
infringing on her lifestyle
and so she killed him
now let's consider the fact that take
this exact same boy
turn the clock back by seven months
and if this mother
had killed him for the exact same reason
would not only be going to prison not
only not be going to prison but we would
be told to celebrate her it's not just
that we would be told to sympathize with
the choice in that case but rather it's
it's a celebration we should we should
literally throw a parade for her
she should shout her abortion from the
rooftops
there would be
you know democrats in congress if they
heard about the case
defending her
i mean that would be someone who the
president of the united states would say
is uh maybe she's a hero too
if she had done almost the exact same
thing
granted she would be killing the child
through a different method not throwing
from her roof but um crushing his skull
so in the end it's basically the same
method
to the doing so doing the same thing to
the same child
for the same reason
but only a few months earlier
and magically it goes from a horrific
murder where we all agree that it's
murder and this is a monster and she
should suffer the consequences it goes
from that too
she is a woman exercising her autonomy
she is a powerful and beautiful person
this is a wonderful thing and we should
celebrate that is incoherent that makes
no sense
and sometimes i i hesitate to make
arguments like this
uh ultimately i do make them because i
think intellectual consistency is so
important
i'm a big fan of intellectual
consistency you figure out what your
principles are what your beliefs are and
you take them to their logical extent
and if what you discover
is that your beliefs and your principles
when taken to their logical extent
lead to horrific things
then that should tell you something
about your beliefs and principles maybe
they need to be changed
so that's why i make the argument but
also
i do sort of worry that we're gonna get
to the point and i think we probably
will get to the point
where the left will hear an argument
like this and they'll say yeah you're
right actually
why can't why can't a mother kill her
infant
we'll probably get to that point and
when we get there at least you're being
intellectually honest
the results will be terrible and
there'll be even more bloodshed but
you're being intellectually honest
because if you would support killing a
child
a second before he's born
which almost every pro-abortion person
does by the way
they support abortion through all of
pregnancy for any reason that is the
mainstream pro-abortion or quote-unquote
pro-choice position right now
long gone are the days when we talk
about abortion should be safe legal and
rare
well they want it to be legal and they
pretend that they can be safe even
though of course it can't be safe
because by definition in an abortion at
least one person is dying
um
but but rare they don't care about that
anymore
but that's that's that's the fact
there's there's there is no there is no
substantive moral difference
between these two things
and you can't say well it's different
because a baby in the womb is dependent
on his mother
because first of all how does dependence
on a person mean that that person can
kill you
let's take that to its logical
conclusion
what about elderly people in nursing
homes
what about people on welfare
who can't take care of themselves and
need the taxpayer i'm a taxpayer can i
just go kill them
they need me they're dependent on me
without my consent
but even more so
little inf this infant seven months old
physically disabled was
100
dependent on his mother on her body on
her time on her very life
in fact a baby outside of the womb
and any mother will tell you this a baby
outside of the womb
is um requires much more from you than a
baby inside the womb
requires more from you in every sense
is even is is
uh
if not more dependent
requires greater sacrifice from you
so if that's a reason justified in the
womb then why not outside
all right let's go uh we'll check out
this from the washington post they
report that the number of white people
fell in this country for the first time
since 1790.
quoting the report it says the report
marks the first time the absolute number
of people who identify as white alone
has shrunk since a census started being
taken in 1790 the number of people
identifying as non-hispanic whites and
no other race dropped by 5.1 million
people to
191.7 million a decrease of 2.6 percent
the country also passed two major uh
milestones on its way to becoming a
majority minority society in the coming
decades for the first time the portion
of white people dipped below 60 slipping
from 63.7
to 57.8 percent in a span of just 10
years and the under 18 population is now
majority people of color at 52.7 percent
that's the report um
and there have been a lot of reactions
to this report like this from jennifer
rubin who responds
a more diverse more inclusive society
this is fabulous news
now uh now we need to prevent minority
white rule
okay
now
we are told
that um
if you speculate
that the powers that be in this culture
want to replace white people
we're told that this is the great
replacement theory
and it is a white supremacist conspiracy
theory and it's pretty much the worst
thing you can ever say
you if you are to say this
uh speculate about this then then you
are a white supremacist that's what
we're told
you can't talk about replacement
and yet huh
i'm just trying to work through this in
my head here
help me out so we're bringing we're
bringing in a flood of immigrants over
the southern border non-white
um
we're putting policies in place with the
express purpose of having fewer white
people in universities and in positions
of power
and we're celebrating the reduction in
the white population
i mean it
it sounds like you want to
replace white people
so this is replacement is it not
and you're happy about it i mean
jennifer rubin is celebrating that
there's fewer you could never do this
with any other race of people
can you imagine if there was a a report
about you know there are fewer uh black
people in the country today than there
were 10 years ago
can you can you imagine anyone reacting
to that and saying this is fabulous news
anyone who did that would be seen as a
genocidal maniac
and if you were to accuse that person of
wanting to replace black people everyone
would say well yeah that's exactly what
he wants to do clearly
yet with white people i mean
you can advocate for replacing them
explicitly
but if anyone
correctly identifies what you're doing
then they're the racist
it's completely absurd now
in fact
i i would even give people on the left
because what i'm saying right now that
is probably going to get clipped by
media matters that's my prediction right
now
um and i hope it is because i want to
get this out in front of of people on
the left
and and you say that the replacement
theory is white white's premise of white
nationalists is a horrible horrible
thing okay
so do you not want to replace white
people
is that
are you saying that you don't want that
you don't want to replace
white people in the population
with a greater portion of non-white
people you don't want to replace white
people in universities and positions of
power
you're saying you don't want that
because while you
uh condemn replacement theory as a white
supremacist
uh you know conspiracy theory i i
noticed that you you don't deny it i
mean you don't come out and say oh no we
don't want to do that
but if you don't then just then say so
and then we're gonna have some follow-up
questions about like okay well then what
what's going on down here on the border
and why do we have these affirmative
action policies in place and why are you
popping champagne and throwing confetti
when there are reports saying that there
are fewer white people
all right let's see uh
speaking of media matters i wanted to
mention this as well before we get to
reading the comments here
um
this is read now from a yahoo news
article about the media matters report
it says youtube offers platform to
anti-trans hate says new report
and and the article says for transgender
people youtube is sometimes hate tube
according to a new research report from
media matters for america i bet they
were proud of that pretty clever
uh while the platform hosts many trans
creators and influencers it also hosts
far-right figures who dead name and
misgender trans folks and it polices
their hateful speech inconsistently says
the report released thursday morning the
offenders include ben shapiro joe rogan
matt walsh michael knowles and a pair
known as the hodge twins they've gone
after prominent transgender people such
as assistant u.s health secretary rachel
levine actress and model lena bloom and
political candidate caitlyn jenner along
with every everyday trans americans for
instance in february walsh a commentator
with the daily wire a right-wing site
derided levine's support of gender
affirming health care for trans youth
that quote should qualify you for a
mental institution or prison not for a
position in government he said
i mean i did say that
but we should clarify that the gender
affirming healthcare for trans youth
um what that means the euphemism there
what we're talking about is the chemical
castration
and sometimes genital mutilation of
miners
who to begin with cannot possibly offer
their consent for that
because according to our laws and our
understanding of childhood psychology
they can't offer their consent for
anything
which is why we don't let them choose we
don't let them make any significant
serious
uh life-altering choices of any kind
and so it is it is hateful speech to
suggest
that maybe that
um
way of viewing children should should
just be extended to this issue of trans
healthcare quote unquote as well
uh knowles also associated with the
daily wire an infamous bigot
repeatedly dead named the misgendered
jenner in an april episode he said if
you're a man who thinks you're a woman
who presents yourself as a woman you're
a seriously confused individual it might
not be a good idea to give you a ton of
political power
um shapiro and the hodgepoints aimed
hate at a trans couple with a child
deriding the mother's effort to
breastfeed the infant
shapiro editor emeritus of the daily
wire called the mother of pervert and
misgendered both parents while
right-wing influencers the hodge twins
said if if you guys was my parents man
i'd probably be a serial killer now
you may remember that um that video
that was
a biological male
attempting to breastfeed a child
and there's a reason to come out pretty
strong against something like that
because if you do that
um and that that's that's especially if
that's the only source of of nutrients
that you're trying to give you're going
to kill the child is going to starve to
death
because men can't breastfeed
but you know trying to protect children
from from being chemically castrated and
generally mutilated at a point when they
cannot consent to it they cannot
possibly psychologically consent to it
or trying to defend babies from starving
to death
because biological males are trying to
breastfeed them
this is anti-trans hate but what you see
again as always
and i'm not going to read the entire
report you get the idea
but
i won't read it on air anyway but i did
i did i did myself read it personally
there was never any attempt
to explain how we're wrong about any of
this
no attempt
because at some level they know they
can't
at some level at some level they know
they see a video of a biological male
trying to breastfeed a child
and they know that this is crazy
and that if you did that too much and if
like if if a if a biological male was to
really believe that he can breastfeed
his child
just like any woman can
then the child will die
a horrible death of starving to death
so at some level even the people of
media matters they know that
which is why they don't make any attempt
to respond to the arguments instead they
say shut these people down
kick them off of the platform for
suggesting that males can't breastfeed
all right let's go now to reading the
youtube comments
this is from brandon says you would most
definitely still have your own head oh
we're talking about okay we're going i i
was talking yesterday about this
discussion i had with uh my
four-year-old about what would happen if
you switched if he switched heads with
his brother
uh important conversation
brandon says you would most definitely
still have your own head and luke's body
everything that makes you you
personality-wise is in your head so
you'll go wherever your head goes i
guess the real question is would luke's
body still be luke's body after all
luke's body is now occupied by your head
and you are your head so i suppose
luke's body would now be your body
occupied by your head and your body
would now be luke's body occupied by his
pet his head conclusion nothing would
change except of course for the bloody
and messy death yeah you know i think
that's the obvious answer for what would
happen if you switched heads but
it's more complicated than it may seem i
mean aside from the logistics of it
because when i talk about you i'm not i
don't like i'm not just talking about
your head right i i'm not sure it's true
to say that you are located
in your head entirely after all your dna
uh your nervous system your bone
structure etc all of this
is also you
and then you add the concept of a soul
into it and then that complicates things
even more does your soul travel
with your head to your other body how
does that work
is the soul located in
the body or in the head
well no not in a literal sense
and given that so much of what
happens in your brain is determined by
what happens elsewhere in your body like
in your nervous system
wouldn't wouldn't putting your head and
your brain on someone else's body change
your brain enough
that you would no longer even exist
so maybe this would really be the
obliteration of both people
and the creation of new people i don't
know
a more interesting form of this question
is maybe i'll ask my four-year-old this
tonight right before bed because it's
the best time for these questions
is what happens if you split your brain
in two pretending this was medically
possible
if you split your brain in two
and gave half your brain to someone else
what happens then where do you go
are you in both places
nowhere
these are the important questions
sean says at the restaurant i manage
we've gone through 14 people in the past
three weeks either they quit they quit
showing up they can't flip a burger or
they have terrible attitudes when their
only job is taking people's money
we have four people working 60 hour
weeks
to keep this restaurant afloat no
millennial is worth hiring they're
incompetent lazy
and or
entitled
uh well
just by the way if you're managing a
restaurant and you're hiring like 19 and
20 year olds
and having this problem those are not
millennials so hey
you know back off a little bit
don't blame us for this that would be
gen z
and you know this look this is always a
complaint like ev every older generation
always says this about the younger
generation a bunch of good for nothing's
and it's never true of everyone in a
generation
and very often
you know the generation making that
accusation they're overlooking all the
great significant flaws of their own
generation such as baby boomers when
they've complained about millennials and
the baby boomer generation basically
destroyed american society almost
single-handedly
um
but it is true that this is a this is a
growing trend in the culture
and it will be as
as each successive generation
is raised in this environment
um
it'll become a greater and greater
problem within that generation
jr crash says it's not hard to imagine
so many young people choosing to take an
early retirement on the government dime
the problem with retirement in old age
is you're usually too tired and broken
to really enjoy it plus a lot of your
friends have drifted away or died it's a
tough sell convincing a young person to
go back to work while their friends make
more money hanging out at the beach
getting drunk yeah it's a tough sell to
people without ambition right
it's definitely a tough sell to them
and but
hard work is always a tough sell to
people without ambition
but if you have ambition
especially as a young person
then it's not difficult at all to it
shouldn't be difficult to sell them on
it
like anyone likes the idea of relaxing
but if you're a person with ambition
and you want to go places in life and
you want to accomplish things and you
want to have success
then you actually wouldn't want
to sit back on the beach every single
day
that would sound like a a horrible fate
if that's all you could do
because you have bigger dreams to go
chase
and i think that's the saddest thing to
see and uh again we can't cast a
this is a broad brush that is true only
in a general sense it's not true for
everyone but
that's the saddest thing to see in in
younger generations and younger people
kind of the death of ambition
because you got to have the ambition
first and then the hard work follows
because no one's gonna go and do any
kind of hard work if they don't have any
some concept of like what their what the
goal is what they're hoping to
accomplish
and uh that's that's that's the hardest
thing
because when you're young i mean that's
that's the time especially when you have
you talk about the energy that you have
and everything
yeah you could whittle that away doing
nothing
but that's also the time with all of
that energy we like talked like we
talked about a few days ago also you
don't have any in most cases you don't
have any kids you don't have any
dependents you're a you're a free agent
you can go anywhere you can do anything
you can take big risks you've got you've
got all that energy as well
[Music]
that's the time to really go chase your
dreams and you find with a lot of young
people now they don't have that desire
um
you see that evidence also even in uh
seemingly less important things like you
look at
little indicators like the average age
for to begin driving has been ticking up
and not because of the laws
but these days kids start on average
driving later than they did when i when
i was a kid or when my parents were kids
because they don't really have the
desire to get out and drive they can but
you know they figure i got everything i
want right here in my house i got my my
phone that's like my whole life i don't
need to drive anywhere
and i can remember when i was a kid i
wanted nothing more
than to get in the car and have that
independence i didn't care where i was
going but the idea of having that
independence being able to go out and do
my own thing was very appealing to me
for a lot of kids today it's just not
appealing
and uh max
says
um okay no actually dustin i'm sorry
says why weren't we wearing masks before
well because we got new information that
encourages us to act and change the ways
we acted previously why did doctors stop
recommending you smoke cigarettes in the
mid-20th century you'll learn new things
it wasn't accustomed to wear masks in
our culture washing hands isn't in
others perhaps no one answered you in
this because it's obvious
okay dustin well
that's the answer to the question that
i've been asking of
if you think that that it's that it's
self-evident to wear a mask now uh and
it's a really basic thing on the level
of washing your hands
then why didn't you wear a mask before
haven't really got an answer you give an
answer i give you credit for that the
problem is the answer is very dumb
because you say that well because we got
new information
and then you also say it wasn't a custom
before but it's a custom now first of
all which is it pick a lane are we doing
it because it's a custom now
i think you're right about that it has
become a custom forced on us
but
many customs are not data driven
you also claim this is data driven we
got new information what is the new
information
okay smoking you give that example
as as science progressed and our
understanding of physiology human
biology and how these things affect our
bodies progressed we learned that
smoking causes cancer that wasn't known
before
what did we learn about masks in the
last 18 months that we didn't know
before
tell me one thing
that's all i'll give you one just give
me one one bullet point give me one
thing
that we learned about masks
since march of 2020
that we didn't know before march of 2020
and i'll give you a chance to answer it
but also answer it for you nothing we
didn't learn anything new there have
been no great advancements in our
understanding of masks and how they work
it's all it's
we knew all of this before
i knew all of this before and i'm not
even a medical professional
and that's the whole point there has
been no new information
so you tried to answer the question but
unfortunately you failed thanks for
trying though
and now it's time for everyone's
favorite part of the show the daily wire
promos buckle up because america is at a
turning point the media and the
government have used fear to spread hate
effectively dividing the nation into
warring factions that are easier to
control with that comes a government
that's gone mad with power is becoming
more tyrannical by the day the onus is
now on freedom-loving americans to stand
up and say no and that's why ben shapiro
wrote a book
which is called the authoritarian moment
and it does a deep dive into the history
of authoritarianism how it's creeping
into our own government and what we can
do to stop it the authoritarian moment
is now available at amazon barnes noble
or any other major bookseller also it's
no secret that candace owens knows how
to light up twitter with her
conservative takes but if you haven't
heard she's now opening her studio to
one lucky vip winner if you sign up now
as a daily wire member with code vip
you'll get 25 off your new membership
and be automatically entered for a
chance to win a trip for two you and a
guest at the daily wire studios to see
candace live not only will you meet
candace you get an inside look at her
studio and front row seats to watch her
take down leftists live in an action on
her talk show candace so get a great
deal on a new dailywire membership at
dailywire.com subscribe with code vip
and 25 off so you can automatically be
entered for a chance to win
the vip experience and finally
everyone sing along with me the morning
wire is now available and it's top in
the charts apple and spotify dominating
the charts but
um we want more and more people to
experience the morning wire which is a
daily news podcast that values your time
and the truth so go and subscribe start
listening now to morning wire and apple
spotify wherever you listen to podcasts
and leave that five star review tell all
your friends about it
and uh now let's get to our daily
cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we
finally have a chance to cancel jen
pasaki she has teetered close a few
times swerving precariously
relief band the writer lizzy wittycomb
which is somehow the perfect name for a
vogue writer lizzie wittycomb tells us
quote
obamaworld was famously famously harsh
with the press
we'll take a side note right after one
sentence yeah we all remember the
famously contentious relationship
between obama and the press i mean the
same press that spent two weeks talking
about obama's tan suit while he was
sending drones out to assassinate
american citizens
anyway uh it says pasaki recalls of the
obama people they're my friends and
they're some of the absolute the most
talented and best people i worked with
in politics but the culture was to yell
at reporters slam the phone down after
traveling with journalists for weeks on
end
and in many cases bonding with them
pasake realized that's never going to be
comfortable to me instead she developed
a more personable report charming her
interlocutors with little jokes asking
about their hometowns and families she's
not a pushover though at one point she
tells me that she hates when people
describe her as nice she says quote it's
like nails on a chalkboard and it still
happens i was introduced to a foreign
delegation in the hallway the other day
as this is jen you may have seen her do
the briefing she's a really nice person
i'm like really you can't think of a
better description
the word is sexist and a little
diminishing but she says it's also this
desire to put people in a box yes
sometimes i'm friendly and joyful and
sometimes i'm tough and sometimes i'm
straightforward
now you have to appreciate how there's
no attempt at an explanation here it
simply asserted that the word nice which
is last i checked the compliment
is not only sexist but diminishing
it's assumed that the reader will
understand how and why this is the case
and no further details are required now
i admit that
i may be a little out of my depth with
this discussion because i have so little
experience with being called nice um if
i was called nice i may actually take it
as an insult but only because i'd assume
that the description was sarcastic like
oh there's matt he's a real nice guy
kind of like the one and only time in my
life when i participated in singing the
happy birthday song to someone
and afterwards a person standing next to
me turned and said wow great singing
voice matt
and walked away laughing
while i ran and locked myself in the
bathroom and wept for hours the whole
scene really ruined my son's birthday
but this is all beside the point how can
a word like nice be considered not only
insulting but sexist
you know i think there are two potential
answers well three
because the first answer is just that
everything is stupid and everyone is
stupid and our culture is a cyclone of
stupid leveling everything in its path
but more specifically uh here are two
other points worth considering first
as we've covered extensively on this
show
in the words of philip reeve we live in
the age of psychological man
and all that matters in our age indeed
the only true reality in our age is how
a person feels about themselves
from the perspective of the individual
self fully immersed in the spirit of the
age the job of everyone else is to
affirm those feelings
and in fact it goes one level deeper
than that and it's more schizophrenic
than that because your job as an
outsider in relation to me
it's not so much to affirm how i feel
about myself
but to affirm how i want to feel about
myself
after all i might feel like an ugly lump
of moldy lard but i want to feel
strong and brave and stunning and
beautiful those are the feelings i'm
trying to
desperately to engender within myself
your job is to somehow identify how i
want to feel
which may or may not be how i actually
feel and affirm it as a reality
my self-actualization to use the new age
jargon is your project
by simply coming in contact with me you
have been thrust into my own internal
drama and you now play a central role
whether you want to or not how does this
relate to jen pasake well
she wants to feel like a tough person at
least sometimes if you encounter her in
one of those moments where she wants to
be as she says tough and straightforward
and you make the mistake of describing
her in a way that conflicts with that
desire then you are attacking her you're
diminishing her
if it sounds like we're at a point where
you simply can't describe another person
or even refer to them without
potentially causing devastating
psychological harm that's correct i mean
that's where we're at
to say anything about another human
being even to refer to them in a neutral
but grammatically correct way is to
potentially undermine the feelings they
want to feel about themselves
and those feelings and desires can
change by the minute especially for
women
no offense which makes the whole thing a
minefield
the second point
is the familiar irony
that gen pasaki is a feminist and
feminists hate men
but idolize them at the same time
i mean what's wrong with being nice well
because jen pasake associates niceness
with women and toughness with men
and she would rather be seen as having
manly qualities because she has decided
that manly qualities are superior
this is what makes female bosses and
managers sometimes so miserable to work
for i mean men can be real jerks too of
course and bad bosses but
females in positions of authority are
more likely to want to be seen as jerks
they're more likely to overcompensate
rejecting their nicer instincts in this
effort to approximate the manliness that
they idolize so it's it's a twisted
picture really
feminists
worship masculinity
but rather than simply appreciating men
and being grateful for them
these people who harbor masculinity
they would rather take the place of men
becoming pale imitations of the thing
they admire
i mean ultimately destroying the very
thing that they admire
and you see it on the other side too you
see men
who worship femininity but rather than
appreciating women and being grateful
for them they try to literally transform
into women and take their place
once again destroying the very thing
that they idolize
so it's quite a confused picture creates
a cultural environment that is
well not very nice to live in
so maybe jen pasake gets her wish in the
end even so she is still today we must
say
canceled
and that'll do it for the day that'll do
it for the week have a great weekend
everybody
godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover our technical director is austin
stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show was edited by sasha tolmachov
our audios mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
21.
john bickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our new show morning wire on
today's episode a battle over masked
mandates erupts in texas oregon schools
make big changes over alleged racism and
a hollywood metoo group is caught up in
a me too scandal join us and get the
facts first on the news you need to know
with our show morning wire